[Musique]
et
le 23 avril dernier lors du premier tour
des élections présidentielles françaises
près d'un jeune sur trois n'est pas allé
voter c'est pas un cas isolé aux
élections législatives qui ont suivi
c'est plus d'un jeune sur deux qui n'a
pas participé il ya beaucoup de facteurs
pour expliquer ça et je vais me
concentrer sur un seul d'entre elles
génération elle a grandi avec internet
wikipedia les réseaux sociaux un
téléphone portable qui fait gps appareil
photo agenda service de taxi à la
demande ou encore agence matrimoniale
elle a aussi grandi avec l'idée qu'on
aura probablement dans un futur proche
des robots qui travailleront à notre
place des voitures autonomes ou encore
des drones qui pourrons nous livrer des
pizzas avant même qu'on songe à les
commander
et puis en même temps que tout ça cette
génération elle a aussi grandi avec un
système politique qui lui n'a pas
tellement évolué ce dernier siècle un
système politique lent et rigide sur son
fonctionnement
sujet à de nombreuses formes de conflits
d'intérêts et de jeux de pouvoir
primaire qui biaise les décisions un
système qui dépense une énergie et des
sommes incroyables dans des élections
qui ressemble souvent plus à une
mauvaise télé réalité qu'un vrai débat
d'idées et qui n'encourage absolument
pas les différents candidats à dire la
vérité ou à reconnaître leurs erreurs à
une époque où on vote tous tous les
jours sur internet à travers nos clics
nos gènes au partage non retweet nos
commentaires nos pétitions
je sais pas vous mais moi ça me paraît
dingue et que notre principal levier sur
la politique ce qui régit notre vie en
commun ce soin de glisser un bout de
papier dans une boîte
une fois tous les cinq ans
la technologie la recherche sociale et
certains exemples de par le monde nous
permettre d'envisager d'autres façons de
fonctionnaires le projet démocratie
daughters a par exemple pour objectif de
mettre en place les outils
technologiques nécessaires à la mise en
place d'une démocratie liquide la
démocratie liquide
c'est un système dans lequel on peut
donner son opinion directement sur les
sujets qui nous intéressent mais aussi
délégué nos voix à des amis des
intellectuels des personnes en qui on a
confiance
si par exemple on n'a pas le temps de se
renseigner sur un sujet où qu'on n'a pas
l'impression d'avoir les expertises
nécessaires
on peut aussi s'appuyer sur des choses
plus concrètes et qui ont déjà fait
leurs preuves comme la suisse ou depuis
maintenant plus d'un siècle le système
en place au niveau national est une
démocratie qu'on peut qualifier de semis
direct le peuple peut à travers des
pétitions demandé l'organisation d'un
référendum facultatif qui permet de
faire abroger une loi qui viendrait
d'être passé par le parlement et à
laquelle une majorité serait opposée
mais il permet aussi aux citoyens de
proposer des toutes nouvelles lois c
écrivent eux-mêmes à travers le
référendum d'initiative populaire
on pourrait se dire que ce genre de
système ça conduit tout droit au chaos
que chacun va voter selon ses intérêts
personnels et qu'au bout de quelques
temps on se retrouve avec un
gouvernement qui autorise ses citoyens à
payer leurs impôts en câlins et en
bisous ou alors dans lequel un salarié
peut licencier son patron c'est
d'ailleurs peut-être pas des idées si
mauvaise que ça mais c'est un autre
débat
le fait est que les suisses ces
dernières années ont refusé deux
semaines de congés payés supplémentaires
et un revenu de base qui leur aurait
garanti un salaire confortable avis sans
avoir besoin de travailler ça paraît
dingue non
certaines études menées en europe
semblent aller dans ce sens en montrant
que les endroits où on offre le plus de
possibilités de s'impliquer dans la vie
politique connaissent des citoyens bien
mieux informés et qu'ils prennent des
décisions plus réfléchies
enfin on peut s'appuyer sur des
initiatives citoyennes telles que le
site internet parlement est citoyen qui
propose aux députés une plateforme pour
organiser des consultations citoyennes
et ainsi nous permettre à tous de
participer à la rédaction et à la
discussion de la loi
je suis de ceux qui pensent que si on
veut aujourd'hui voir émerger des idées
audacieuses plus à même de répondre aux
grands défis du 21e siècle
il va falloir qu'on songe sérieusement à
faire évoluer le cadre dans lequel elles
évoluent et si on trouve aujourd'hui le
temps pour fabriquer des miroirs à celle
fille et des fourchettes connecter des
fourchettes connectés j'ai aucun doute
sur le fait qu'on puisse trouver un peu
de temps pour mettre à jour nos
institutions mais l'un des principaux
défis qui se posent à nous tous sur
cette question c'est celle de
l'information dans une démocratie où le
peuple est souverain
l'information a un impact majeur sur
l'opinion publique et donc une influence
sur le pouvoir lui-même
aujourd'hui notre information elle a
principalement de deux canaux
le premier c'est les médias
traditionnels la presse écrite qu'elle
soit numérique ou papier la télévision
ou encore la radio
ces journalistes traditionnels
on leur reproche souvent un certain
manque d'indépendance et ainsi de
neutralité
on pourrait parler du fait que dans des
pays comme la france ou les états unis
la majorité des grands médias est détenu
par une poignée de multimillionnaires et
de grands groupes mais on en apprend en
fait beaucoup plus quand on s'intéresse
au contexte économique dans lequel
évoluent ces entreprises la publicité
pouces par exemple beaucoup de ces
médias à ne pas être en compétition pour
obtenir des abonnés mais pour obtenir du
temps d'attention ou comme dirait l'ex
pdg de tf1 du temps de cerveau
disponible
la presse en ligne gratuite ne mesure
pas la valeur d'un article
à combien il aura aidé à nous éclairer à
nous informer mais à son nombre de clics
et de partage
dans ce contexte pourquoi parler d'un
groupe citoyen qui tenteraient de
rénover la politique quand on parlait du
dernier scandale dans la vie privée d'un
politicien célèbre nous assure beaucoup
plus de tant d'attention pourquoi parler
des choses qui vont bien
des associations qui font progresser des
causes depuis des années quand la
meilleure façon de s'assurer des revenus
reste de jouer sur la peur le
sensationnalisme ou encore en sortant
les dernières rumeurs en exclusivité
quitte à ne pas bien vérifier si elles
sont fondées ou qu'elles impactent leurs
révélations pourraient avoir récemment
vous avez peut-être vu passer dans la
presse toute une série d'articles nous
mettant en garde contre la dangereuse
baisse du quotient intellectuel français
une partie de la presse s'est amusé à
nous expliquer pourquoi nous étions tous
de plus en plus bête
sauf que quand on lit les quatre petites
pages de l'étude sur laquelle s'appuient
tous ces articles pour justifier une
baisse de 4 points du cully français
sent vite compte qu'elle a été menée sur
un échantillon minuscule seulement 79
personnes âgées d'entre 30 et 63 ans qui
ne représente pas du tout un panel
représentatif de la population française
l'étude elle-même met en garde en
précisant que ces données doivent être
recoupées et ré-analyser avant de
pouvoir tirer ce genre de conclusion le
noyau de l'information la donner a
toujours un contexte démission est une
façon d'être présente et auquel on doit
faire attention si les médias
traditionnels sont pas forcément neutre
au fond c'est pas très grave
c'est pas très grave parce que c'est
parce qu'on leur demande ce qu'on leur
demande c'est d'être critique et
pointures si le but des médias c'est de
nous éclairer et de faire progresser les
opinions et les débats dans le sens du
bien commun alors il est important
qu'ils puissent prendre position c'est à
nous de vérifier que cette position
elle est argumentée et source est un
média sein devrait toujours mentionné
les potentiels conflits d'intérêts
auxquels ils s'exposent en publiant un
article et la façon dont il mène ses
investigations devraient toujours être
là plus tôt
ce pas rendu possible notre deuxième
canal d'information c'est le journalisme
citoyen les blogs les plateformes de
vidéos en ligne mais aussi nos postes à
tous sur les réseaux sociaux
ce journalisme citoyen on lui reproche
souvent d'être un générateur de félix
news en français des bobards dans
lesquelles il nous est tous arrivé de
tomber
si la presse parodique
elle nous en montre le côté drôle et
décalé tout en jouant un rôle éducatif
les fausses informations et plus
généralement le peu de rigueur
journalistique peuvent avoir des
conséquences très néfastes sur le débat
public
il est par exemple extrêmement difficile
d'avoir un débat constructif sur
internet à propos de sujets importants
comme les vaccins sans que toute une
série d'articles basées sur des
informations de nombreuses fois démenti
réapparaissent ce journalisme citoyen on
lui reproche aussi souvent d'alimenter
ce qu'on appelle des bulles
d'information un réseau social comme
facebook dont l'objectif commercial et
de nous garder le plus longtemps
possible sur leur page a tout intérêt à
nous montrer du contenu qui va dans le
sens de nos intérêts mais aussi de nos
opinions et ça ça nous fait remet petit
à petit aux opinions différentes des
nôtres
on a donc d'un côté des médias
traditionnels qui peine parfois à sortir
de leur cadre politique et économique
il en a de l'autre des journalistes
citoyens qui produisent une information
abondante mais souvent trop peu vérifier
et au milieu de tout ça y est nous tous
si consommons de l'information au
quotidien nous et notre temps
d'attention toujours plus courts nous et
nos nombreux biais et notamment le biais
de confirmation
ce mécanisme par lequel on peut montrer
99 article factuel attestant du
réchauffement climatique à quelqu'un qui
n'y croient pas il retiendra toujours
que le seul et unique article qui va
dans son sens
pourquoi vouloir entendre la vérité
quand on peut entendre qu'on a raison
c'est donc l'information
on doit la vérifier mais à part les
journalistes dont c'est le métier
on n'a pas tous le temps de croiser nos
sources et de vérifier chaque chiffre
pour tous les sujets qu'on lit et
pourtant tout à l'heure je vous disais
ma génération elle a grandi avec
wikipedia la force de wikipédia c'est
d'avoir réussi à créer une plateforme
collaborative sur laquelle c'est la
multiplicité et la diversité des
contributions qui crée une certaine
forme de neutralité et la majorité des
études sur la question sans tente à le
dire wikipedia en tout cas sur les
sujets principaux est au moins aussi
fiable que n'importe quel autre
encyclopedia notamment parce qu'elles
demandent systématiquement des sources
et si on essayait d'appliquer les mêmes
principes
mais avec notre information du quotidien
il ya bientôt un an
j'ai commencé à travailler sur un projet
captain fact dont l'objectif est de
créer et d'expérimenter des outils
numériques qui pourrait nous aider à
mieux consommer et à mieux digérer
l'information
le premier de ces outils il nous permet
par exemple lorsqu'on regarde une vidéo
sur internet d'avoir des informations
qui viennent se superposer pour
confirmer infirmer
dans tous les cas pour sourds c'est ce
qu'on est en train de voir un autre
outil qui lui est toujours en
développement permettrait de faire la
même chose mais avec des articles en
ayant la possibilité de voir directement
les points sur lesquels on doit faire
attention avec des liens vers des
sources potentiellement contradictoires
enfin l'idée c'est de réunir toutes ces
informations fournies par la communauté
sur une plateforme qui nous permettent
de débattre de manière beaucoup plus
précise que ce que permettent
aujourd'hui les différents systèmes de
commentaire en travaillant au point par
point
argument par argument et non plus en
traitant tout le contenu d'un seul bloc
on peut être d'accord avec certains
points est en désaccord avec d'autres le
tout avec des mécaniques de jeu tels que
la réputation ou des médailles
afin de plus facilement faire remonter
le contenu de qualité un commentaire
source et rapporte par exemple sur
captain fact toujours plus de points
qu'un simple commentaire d'opinion si
tout ça ça peut nous aider
un outil sa réseau rarement tous les
problèmes wikipedia malgré ses
nombreuses qualités subit toujours des
guerres d'édition là par exemple ce
qu'on appelle là ce trotteur des grandes
compagnies par exemple dans le domaine
pharmaceutique met en place des moyens
financiers importants pour influencer
des pages afin par exemple de gommer des
aspects négatifs de leurs produits
si on veut demain construire des
sociétés plus participative
il ya un travail que rien ni personne ne
va pouvoir faire à notre place
celui de développer et d'en durcir nos
esprits critiques et pour ça il ya
quelque chose auquel on peut faire
attention au quotidien acceptons qu'il
n'a souvent pas dans nos opinions
politiques de vérité absolue puisque
celles ci sont basés sur nos
interprétations personnelles de ce que
devrait être la liberté l'égalité et
plus généralement le vivre ensemble
suivront des médias et des bâtons avec
des gens aux opinions différentes des
nôtres afin de percer la bulle
lorsqu'on débat attaques ont toujours
les idées et pas les personnes
critiquer le jeu pas les joueurs soyons
sceptiques de tous ne pas croire sans
preuve
bien entendu je parle pas de religion
ici
méfions nous du hooligan politique qui
sommeille en chacun de nous vous savez
c'est celui qui nous pousse à cliquer
sur partagé alors qu'on n'a pas encore
lu l'article
on l'a tous fait enfin considérons
peut-être de devoir payer pour assurer
l'indépendance des médias qui en valent
la peine
ou en tout cas gardons toujours à
l'esprit que l'information gratuite
n'est jamais
réellement gratuite quelqu'un d'autre
l'a payé pour nous merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]